hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for no good today's
gonna be one of the shorter videos of
this month but it is a dead stream day 7
there was an adept stream but there was
a blog post so we're gonna be talking
about that we have a road map and other
stuff to get into so as always like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe for new I
covered the informational SATA fauna
that being the balance changes the here
updates the Patrick's and the leaks
butter he kept those today with
everything happening within the world of
phone or definitely subscribe the
channel with that guys let's get into
today's video
so first up a little schedule to let you
guys know September 5th is today
September 12th will be next Thursday the
19th is the Thursday after that and then
the last Thursday of September is the
26th all of those days are going to be
blog posts except the 19th and we'll get
into why it's the 19th I've pretty much
called it yesterday as I was thinking
about this but we'll get into that just
to let you guys know what the schedule
is going to be like for this month phase
one of the testing grant has just went
light you know went live I believe last
week but it you know it's still in the
process hopefully you guys have played
in hopefully you guys have filled out
the survey for it and they wanted to
leave us with a little bit of feedback
they're liking a lot of the stuff that
were given to them and also there was a
bug-fix regarding that that they're good
that just came out today is what they
fixed in the maintenance they ended up
fixing a bug that was live in the game
for the testing ground but they fixed it
during the maintenance basically if you
and another teammate were playing a
Centurion and both of you had stamina
you could constantly back-to-back Eagle
talons the opponent has provided of
course you guys had stamina to do so
this was completely unintentional and
that is fixed so that's not going to be
within the testing grounds this only
occurred in the testing grounds not in
the full game for some reason it may
have to do with something else regarding
his kit I'm just no one's still really
sure on why that's the case but if that
happened to you that's not going to be
happening anymore sadly there is not
going to be an event challenge for this
week so nobody's going to be getting
some extra steel or Lu crates but that's
ok we'll probably get some next week but
we have the main part of this video
which is the September roadmap all the
way from September 5th to the 27th of
September so let's go ahead and dive
deep into what that is so on September
5th nothing really crazy except that we
have an arcade quest like I stated
there's on September 12th we have the
Tuttle update year 3 season 3 title
update 2 as it says on the roadmap
I'm assuming that's just going to be
like the midseason patch notes we might
get some decent changes to the main cast
maybe some other changes in the testing
grounds that we can test it a little bit
more and give the developers their
feedback so definitely look out for a
video next week if there's gonna be some
nice little patch notes on that I'm
curious see what they're gonna give to
us as well as content of the week and a
new arcade quest I think the new content
of the week for September 12th might
actually be the email contest that we
had last month because I'm not seeing
any other content of the week other than
on the 19th so it's all there going to
be then or on the 19th we might get some
of those new emotes and we could finally
see those winners and finally good seed
in game on the 13th of September will be
getting the ranked slayer challenge from
September 13 to the 16th so basically
that weekend and then year three season
three the fourth version or the fourth
round of the campaign is going to be
starting with the fifth campaign
starting on the 27th so honestly we're
kind of speed running through this game
era this season it feels like it just
started a month ago when technically it
did but it's just that it just feels
like we've gone through like a couple
days and we're already through a month
it just feels weird to me and then the
biggest info is that on the 19th we're
getting our seasonal event no idea what
that's going to be but that's gonna be
having some weekly rkb the quests we're
gonna have some event orders gonna have
an event playlist some content of the
week and the seasonal event all coming
together I'm assuming that event
playlist is going to have something to
do with a new game-mode coming for the
event as we usually have had this year
and obviously throughout all the other
seasons of events we've had before no
idea what this is going to be about only
that it's probably most likely going to
be something with your man gunner and
some lore that's all I'm really getting
from this anything else I have no other
details about that so I'll definitely be
interested to see what's gonna be
happening there on this 26th we're gonna
be getting some arcade quests and then
on the 27th there's an extra loot fest
this will be good because this kind of
ties into the event loot if you guys
want to get that extra bit of loot I'll
have a video on how to get the loot the
fastest for that event as well and then
also pair that up with the weekend
coming with the extra loot fest it's
gonna be getting mad loot everywhere
hopefully event loot is actually really
cool I'd love to see what it is that's
gonna be basically the end of the video
hope you guys did enjoy sorry if you
were looking at my community post and I
said there wouldn't be a dead stream
video today I checked at like 2 o'clock
and there was nothing this came out like
five minutes after I sent that so feels
bad for me and also just in case you've
made it to the end of this video
definitely be sure to leave a like but
also if you see a lot of Monster Hunter
video
coming within the next week or so
Osbourne is releasing on the same day
that this is going out later tonight and
I'm gonna be staying up all night to
record as many videos as I can try to
get that out within the week it's gonna
be a bunch of guides for the quest that
we're gonna be getting for ice born as
well as a bunch of the monster guides as
well for the newer monsters we're
getting some old some new some variation
stuff like that it's gonna be crazy so
if you guys do want to watch those
videos I highly recommend you do but if
you don't I understand just at least if
you're not going to watch the video
through the whole thing I understand
just at least going and like the video
and then you can leave afterwards would
be greatly appreciated hey guys let me
know what you guys think about the new
event let me know as specifically what
you guys think this is going to be based
around cuz it has to do something with
the Vikings your main Gander I'm very
curious to see what this is about maybe
we'll get some mythology stuff in there
really curious if it's gonna be what
that's going to be about but yet
definitely like the video if you do
enjoy guys subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational SATA form that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the Patchett's and the leaks if
you wanna be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
Warner and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribe the channel
other guys thank you for watching the
video peace out have a great ass today
[Music]
you
[Music]